hallo mein name ist khan herzlich
willkommen zu einem spielen ein spiel
das spiel was wir heute spielen heißt
space talks und das ist balu da also
wirklich jetzt sieht nicht nur aus wie
balu sondern das soll wirklich bydesign
in dieser apps von os das ist der ist
von von waikiki falls ihr die noch kennt
er hatte mich gefragt ihr und lukas du
irgendwie lust daran dass deinen hund
balu in der app mit drin und gar da wird
der kleine serie gerade eingeblendet das
ist so ein ähnliches spiel wie wie das
dann kann ich weiß nicht was es sich
ähnelt ihr können auf play drücken und
spielen dann quasi hier diesen ball und
kann entweder durch fingertippen immer
den zudem nächsten stern hier schleudern
oder wir können auch einfach so nehmen
und quasi überall durchfliegen ihr habt
vielleicht schon zu beginn gesehen ich
habe schon riesig viele sterne gesammelt
weil ich echt ein bisschen süchtig
geworden bin von diesem spiel ich muss
allerdings auch dazu sagen ich bekomme
dafür nicht dass ich das spiel erzählt
zocke ich muss nichts positives sagen
aber ich finde ich find's cool
eigentlich man muss nicht unbedingt
diese sterne sammeln ich kann auch ich
kann natürlich auch einfach sterben da
oben seht ihr schon insgesamt 500 750
sterne gesagt mit kam habe ich schon
profen eigentlich hab ich habe grade
flugmodus drin und eigentlich hat die
app auch noch ton nur kann man premiere
das gerade irgendwie nicht so ganz
alleine deswegen soll ich das kann ohne
ton also ich kann auch hier neben dem
planeten wie herfliegen und muss nicht
die sterne einsammeln allerdings kann
ich mir von sternen ich glaube davon
kann ich mir nachher irgendwas holen
beziehungsweise haben wir dadurch ein
leaderboard status das ist so die app er
ich bin schon wieder tot es wird halt
nachher immer komplizierter also das
wird schneller und die teile sind näher
aneinander und man kommt ja nicht ob die
teile sind gar nicht mehr aneinander
aber es wird einfach schneller und
dadurch kommt es mir so vor ich möchte
jetzt gerade schon wie die teile einfach
immer näher aneinander sind und alles so
ein bisschen an fahrt gewinnt das könnte
gerade sogar mein bester dann werden man
will irgendwie immer alle sterne
einsammeln obwohl man es eigentlich gar
nicht muss alter und jetzt gerade merkt
man dass es hätten
es denken so viele dass ich mich
geprügelt habe aber das ist wirklich nur
vom boxsack also nicht dass ihr euch
wundert irgendwie weiß nicht wieso das
hier alles so ist das ich habe gegen den
boxsack geschlagen weil ich wütend war
dass gegen geboxt und der boxer hat mir
voll gegeben
das feuer in trays außerdem ihr das
video gerade seht bin ich in new york
beziehungsweise samstag das heißt
übermorgen zügig weiter nach raleigh
weil ich da bei der welt-premiere bin
von diesem prank film und in der laser
25 grad und sonne und das wird
unglaublich cool und darauf freue ich
mich schon voll und ich war noch niemals
in new york war ich ja schon mal und ich
hab eigentlich für mich festgehalten
hatte dass wird voll das lama video
gerade ich hoffe ihr habt nichts dagegen
wie man das ist bei solchen es
eigentlich immer so dass man versucht
natürlich irgendwie das beste zu
erreichen allerdings weiß man ja hier
dass man erstmal wie kann es denn sein
gesicht genau die erde abstürzen
man braucht halt erstmal voll lange bis
zu diesem punkt wo man sagt okay jetzt
kann ich nicht wirklich nur noch aufs
game konzentrieren deswegen werde ich
jetzt noch mal schnell sagen in new york
war ich ja schon da habe ich auch blogs
gemacht ich nicht vergesse verlege ich
euch verlinkt ich euch mal einen blog
ich bin schon wieder tot sehe ich gerade
einen blog meine ich natürlich da habe
ich euch mal einen blog verlinkt das war
einer wo ich in new york war dieses mal
wenn ich in new york bzw sein werde
werde ich nur ich werde zwar die kamera
mitnehmen und werde sehr viel filmen und
festhalten und so aber ich werde denke
ich nur am ende einen blog machen der
dann vielleicht fünf minuten geht wenn
ich schnell eine zusammenfassung oder 20
minuten wenn ich viel gefilmt habe aber
auf jeden fall ein blog über die 67 tage
die ich dann weg bin und nicht jeden tag
was hochladen weil das war in new york
irgendwie so stressig dass man immer die
kamera mit dabei hatte und so natürlich
ist es auf der einen seite cool dass
wenn man eine kamera dabei hat weil ich
einfach für euch gute sachen einhalt
ein ich bin schon wieder tot ich kann
für euch coole sachen festhalten und hab
kohleblocks und macht auch unglaublich
spaß blogs zu schneiden also viel mehr
spaß als gaming videos auch wenn es
vielleicht nicht so rüberkommt weil man
sieht einfach immer was anderes beim
gaming sehe ich mich immer diese eine
position hier vorne und weiß genau
welche ich bin die sowieso sterbe ich so
auf meinem blog ist es halt immer
woanders aber ist ja scheiß egal
jedenfalls finde ich dass man den man
immer eine kamera dabei hat lebt man
quasi durch diese kamera und viele
momente kommen nicht so rüber weil man
halt nur sagt so typische slot trip
beispiel von den jungs zu walter da sind
nordlichtern anstatt dass ich würde mich
da einfach hinsetzen und würde mich da
hinlegen und vielleicht an das einfach
mal genießen anstatt an die kamera
hinzustellen mit time lab zu machen und
ins netz statt darüber zu reden wie toll
alles ist solo das ist ein bisschen das
ding da steht mich da nicht falsch ich
finde es unglaublich cool dass die bei
dem northridge kohleblocks machen und so
butt aber ich glaub im feld wenn das
video online kommt sind die dann
überhaupt noch ich weiß es nicht ich war
volks auch alles nicht so genau aber ich
sehe halt das sich alle jeden tag was
hochladen aber ich bin einfach nicht so
ein typ ich will lieber genießen und hab
dann das ist urlaub sage ich mal
das ist für mich dann wirklich urlaub
natürlich macht mir auch spaß so videos
zu bearbeiten und ich sehe es jetzt auch
nicht als beruf an oder so es ist
allerdings ein bisschen die sache wenn
ich nach dem praktikum um 19 uhr zu
hause bin und morgen schon um 7 oder 36
aufgestanden bin hab ich dann noch lust
einfach mal frühpension gehen und nicht
noch vier stunden ein video zu schneiden
das ist könnt ihr euch so vorstellen den
fußballer den ganzen tag auf dem
fußballplatz ist auch irgendwann mal so
und sagt brauche ich liebe zwar den
sport aber jetzt gerade muss ich erstmal
schlafen
versteht ihr was ich meine deswegen wird
das halt so ein bisschen also bekommt
auf jeden fall block am ende aber der
reise erst dann wird der halter ahnung
wie lange ich weiß auch gar nicht wie
ich darauf gekommen bin wir fliegen hier
weiter um die planeten rum ich glaube
das sind sogar das wird auf jeden fall
wir haben die erde
er glaube ich den mond und ich weiß
nicht was wir da haben wir die ganzen
anderen sachen einfach mal pinkeln oder
grün es wird gerade immer schwieriger
hier ihnen herum zu kommen aber mein
ziel sind einfach mal 100 ich habe
insgesamt 1000 das ziel für dieses video
sind 100 sterne einzusammeln freunde das
ist doch nicht so schwer also
anscheinend es ist schon schwer aber ich
bin auch ich bin auch echt schlecht die
app heißt übrigens pace dogs falls ich
das noch nicht gesagt habe die gibt es
für android und ios werde das video sie
es tut mir leid das mein kanal ich
vergess einfach mal zu erwähnen was wir
zocken man es ist ein suchtfaktor ich
will es unbedingt schaffen diese blöden
100 voll zu kriegen es sieht so aus als
wäre ich auf einem guten weg haben schon
die 50 geknackt 55 je weil dadurch 60
vor allem an weiß wann immer ich bin tot
und ich muss jetzt wieder eine minute ca
erstmal zu der stelle hinkommen die eine
minute ist jetzt vielleicht übertrieben
aber man muss auf jeden fall erstmal
wieder so ein bisschen hilft diese pampa
fliegen bis man nach oben hin kommt
deshalb voll cool wenn man ihm die
checkpoints einsammeln könnte so nach
dem motto okay wenn du einmal die 100
sterne erreicht das ist es die möglich
bei den nächsten fünf bis zehn runs oder
bei allen nächsten land ist es die
möglich oder gestartet ab 100 zu starten
so dass man quasi nicht exakt zum
kleiner ball fliegt hoch wieso hab ich
eigentlich nicht weil du auf meiner
schulter sitzen als schaut man können
sich sogar mir andere noch auswählen wir
jetzt nicht muss jetzt balu einmal
nehmen wenn ich den ja schon oft
schulter-op es wäre einfach so krassen
das ist jetzt der erste raum mit balu
und ich werde danach auch kein land mit
baidu machen weil ich da noch kurz eine
andere figur testen möchte aber wenn wir
jetzt 100 schaffen alter wird es einfach
nur an balu liegen bei meinen augen tue
das auch ein bisschen wie ich kommen
hier hoch und alles ist auf einmal wird
halt immer schneller und die augen
kommen überhaupt nicht hinterher und am
schlimmsten ist wenn man an sozialem um
die 73 buy belassen in guten dienst
erwiesen wir klicken jetzt einfach mal
auf die anderen hunde und wählen jetzt
beispielsweise mal den dass das schwein
hieraus und jetzt schaue ich mal auf das
schwein irgendwie sachen kann oder kann
die schießen oder so ich glaube das
schwein sind einfach noch anders aus man
schwein mit dir wird möglich sein dass
ich es schaffe und die straffe wie ich
es mache und ich bin verdammt nach
der tod an dieser stelle beendet das war
richtig laut gerade an dieser stelle
endlich das video mir hat spaß gemacht
hier findet die app im app store unter
dem namen space talks wenn ihr mehr lust
auf das ich so handy games zocken dann
schreibt mir das gerne und in die
kommentare oder zeigten über eine
bewertung und dann sehen wir uns
vielleicht bei instagram wenn ich in
amerika bilder hochladen oder chat ist
alles in der beschreibung oder halt
irgendwann morgen oder kann